here we go we got C-SPAN pulled up right  here ladies and gentlemen as you are  tuning into this segment what can you  see motion to adjourn Republicans 219  Democrats 212 one Republican voted no  but it looks like the yeas have it and  our lazy members of Congress who did  nothing but sit there all day are voting  to go home without getting the job done  well I guess to be fair even those Brave  We the People votes of the Republican  party like Matt Gates Lauren bobert  Biggs Etc Cloud I think Collide as well  a lot of people there's like 20 people  20 21 they're also voting to go home so  fine fine whatever I suppose if it means  more gridlock and nothing's happening I  guess the argument is it's a good thing  you know I don't know Luke seems to be  pretty it's a great thing it's it's a  beautiful thing because the longer  Congress fights with itself the less  they could fight against the American  people and you know 11 times rookie  numbers